you said he talked about magic and what
domesticated zombies
he talked about the good work people
don't know didn t know delirious people
will say anything he was holding this
map when we brought him in whoa did this
looks like a way out of her on crane we
are running out of antigen we have to
explore every possibility we can't wait
any longer
their way stand in your way you don't
understand the brothers mother
lena d copy came comic you're breaking
up yeah listen you're one egg delirious
patient he was telling the truth there
is a way out maybe what he said about
people who don't turn his true he died
this morning Kyle the favor got him you
are on your own I'm afraid Lena Lena
yeah [ __ ] mountains
place looks occupied
what do you want I need to talk to
someone in charge I'm from her on oh you
he's smuggler you work for the group oh
look I don't know anything about any
smuggling pal i'm here just I need some
help as for adjusted but understand this
if you steal anything you lose your
hands
I've got my eye on you stranger
hi excuse me I don't know anything look
could you just tell me where to find
someone who does know something look for
the jazzy it'll be inside the bottom
excuse me East we don't talk to
strangers ah
need something are you doing in charge I
need some help talk to Jesse here
father please can't beat all these no
end of discussion fine fine esky wait
esky I don't mean to interrupt I'm
looking for jizz ear I am busier but if
you want food we have only bread no no I
don't need food listen i'm from her on
and I've come because I've heard that
there are people here who are immune to
the virus that they don't turn even if
they get bitten oh and who told you this
a dead man i'm sorry to say you might as
well keep listening to him i'll tell you
no more than he [ __ ] hell why won't
anybody help me the virus is all over
the city people are dying and yet you
still live take some bread my friend and
go back to her on no one wants you here
well you know this is crane d copy
damelin [ __ ] wasteland hey yeah you
come here come on come closer I won't
bite you don't worry I like the rest of
these loonies yeah I'm talking about you
you're not jobs so you're not one of
them why aren't they were trying to run
you off as I sell more [ __ ] than just
bread my name is khan by the way kyle
crane hey you from her arm right but you
run to my optical challenge buddy you
mean the guy with an i missing yeah
that's the one my boy could how's he
doing oh yeah yeah he didn't make it
well that's a damn shame but can't say
I'm surprised maybe you can help me Kurt
said the people out here are immune to
the virus you know anything about that
now that you mention it I don't remember
any of the locals actually turning
[ __ ] lactose during a damn cult led
by some woman they call them mother used
to be just a harmless local tradition
Oh
oh forgot to tell you if you ain't got
none like yourself some weapons farms
abandoned outpost what you forgot to
tell me this I'd like we're off to a
good start hide what you got the car
there's that [ __ ] ain't gonna stand
you forever
can I go
you